les demandes de recours collectif se
multiplient les voyageurs n'accepte pas
que les transporteurs aériens refusent
de leur accorder des remboursements pour
des vols annulés depuis le début de la
pandémie
il ya beaucoup de lois de voix qui
s'élèvent de l'aborder on doit obliger
des guinéens de rembourser comme ce
corps l'europe comme c'est le cas aux
états unis
la plus récente requête vient de new
yorkais contre air canada
ils réclament près de 3000 $ pour un
voyage en colombie britannique qui n'a
pas eu lieu
air canada lui propose un crédit qui
expirera dans deux ans c'est totalement
inacceptable qu'on voit de prendre en
otage l'argent les gens qu'ils abhorrent
débit clients finalement qui eux avaient
planifié voyage est long la crise
partout au monde on espère garder
remboursées sauf au canada au québec
l'attitude des transporteurs aériens va
à l'encontre du code civil
il faut qu'elle pense à que le
commerçant peut importe les
circonstances a que ce soit la pandémie
n'est pas s'il n'est pas en mesure
d'honorer son implication il est tenu de
restituer des sens qui on peut payer
ottawa a même été interpellé sur la
question cette semaine le ministre des
transports demeure complètement un
silencieux pourquoi est-ce qu'ils talaki
compagnies aériennes confisqué l'argent
dont les gens ont besoin pour payer
leurs factures
les lignes aériennes en ce moment
souffrent dans le sens qu'ils ont perdu
95 % de leurs revenus et ont quand même
des coûts fixes à payer alors la
situation est très de son côté
l'association des agents de voyages du
québec appuie la décision des compagnies
aériennes sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'on veut qu entre de confinement
et la crise est finie que les gens
puissent continuer de voyager et que
l'infrastructure soit encore en place
c'est tous les fournisseurs ont failli
être ça pourrait être plus difficile
pour les gens de voyager le dossier est
épineux le gouvernement ou les tribunaux
devront trancher
et si maxime bertrand radio canada
montréal